une seconde audition elle prononge nos
échanges précédents qui ont porté sur la
situation économique et l'actualité en
se penchant plus précisément sur un
sujet très important qui est la
défaillance
d'entreprise nous recevons donc Monsieur
Frédéric Abitbol président du Conseil
national des administrateurs judiciaires
et des mandataires judiciaires et
Monsieur Michel Pellier président de la
Conférence générale des juges
consulaires de France messieurs soyez
d'ors et déjà remerciés de vous être
rendu disponible pour cette matinée
d'échange pour introduire nos échanges
je souhaiterais verser au débat quelques
chiffres tirés des dernières études de
la banque de franceces et qui se sont et
qui sont reproduits sur les diapositives
qui vont être projetés à l'écran les
défaillances d'entreprise sont en forte
hausse depuis 2 ans alors que l'on
dénombrait 2500 défaillances en moyenne
tous les mois en 2020 et 2021 ce chiffre
est passé à 3400 en 2022 et 4500 en
2023 messieur grâce à votre expertise et
à votre regard concret nous
souhaiterions comprendre comment doit
être lu cette hausse s'agit-il d'un
rattrapage post covid qui sanctionne les
difficultés d'entreprise maintenu
artificiellement en vie par les aides
décidées lors de la crise sanitaire et
de la relance certains signaux semblent
Poés en ce sens la tendance étant la
même dans toute l'Europe et étant
cohérente avec les niveau de défaillance
long terme
ou bien doit-on la comprendre comme un
signal d'alerte
notamment si l'on regarde plus finement
les catégories d'entreprise concernées
par exemple la hausse est bien plus
forte pour les petites entreprises plus
79 % que pour les moyennes entreprises
plus 55 % et certains secteurs sont
particulièrement frappés le commerce de
proximité restauration si c'est
effectivement un signal de retournement
de conjoncture quelles en sont les
raisons la hausse des coûts une
croissance trop faible une profitabilité
insuffisante selon certains analystes la
hausse des défauts poursuivrez en
2024 jusqu'où peut-elle aller selon vous
et surtout que peut-on faire pour mieux
prévenir la survenue de défaillance
Messieurs les Présidents je vous laisse
sans plus attendre la parole pour un
propos liminire je vous remercierai de
ne pas dépasser 10 minutes chacun et
afin que nous puissions euh avec nos
collègues réagir et échanger sur vos
propos je vous rappelle que cette table
ronde est retransmise en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat puis en vidéo à
la demande en suite
je vous en
prie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président donc Frédric peut-être un mot
rapide de présentation pour que vous
sachiez qui vous parle donc moi je suis
administrateur judiciaire à Paris je
suis le président du Conseil national
des administrateurs et des mandataires
judiciaires spécificité française nous
avons en France un système dans lequel
quand une entreprise est en difficulté
il y a pas un professionnel mais deux
professionnels qui sont nommés un
administrateur judiciaire don le métier
est d'accompagner le redressement de
l'entreprise et de Saver l'entreprise et
l'emploi à chaque fois que c'est
possible et un mandataire judiciaire
dont le travail est de représenter
l'intérêt des créanciers et si besoin de
liquider l'entreprise de vendre ses
actifs et d'en répartir le produit au
profit des créanciers euh les
professionnels français sont au nombre
d'à peu près 500 à peu près 150
administrateurs judiciaires un peu plus
de 300 mandataires judiciaires et nous
traitons en rythme annuel historiquement
sur le long terme environ 50000
entreprises le système français est
caractérisé par le fait que le droit
français se fixe un objectif très clair
qui est de sauver l'entreprise et
l'emploi c'est pas le cas partout en
Allemagne l'objectif c'est de payer les
créanciers les deux objectifs sont
parfaitement légitimes quand une
entreprise en difficulté au sens où on
parle de défaillance c'est une
entreprise qui ne paye pas ses dettes
c'est donc une anomalie et il y a deux
intérêts également légitimes qui sont
pose l'entreprise qui veut vivre et les
créanciers qui veulent être payé chacun
chaque droit de l'Union européenne fixe
fixe ses règles et ses priorités on est
en train d'harmoniser mais la France se
caractérise par cette vision très claire
d'abord et avant tout on veut sauver les
boîtes on veut sauver les emplois si on
peut payer les créanciers c'est bien
mais d'abord on sauve les entreprises et
les emplois encore une fois c'est pas le
cas partout c'est pas le cas en
Allemagne c'est pas le cas aux Pays-Bas
c'est pas le cas en Angleterre c'est pas
le cas dans plein
d'économies le système français se
caractérise par le fait qu'il est
extrêmement efficace du point de vue des
objectifs qu'il s'assigne en France les
entreprises en difficulté sauvegarde
redressement liquidation judiciaire
conduisent dans leur traitement au
sauvetage du des 2/ers des emplois donc
quand une entreprise dépose son bilan
statistiquement on va sauver les 2/ers
des
emplois quand on se compare à
l'Allemagne à l'Angleterre au Pays-Bas
ils sont en dessous de 10 %. c'est pas
qu'on est meilleur c'est qu'on fait pas
la même chose à l'évidence on fait pas
la même chose bon mais de ce point de
vue là il faut avoir en tête que le
droit est très efficace je vous disais
500 professionnels à peu près 50000
dossiers par an on se dit ben ça fait
beaucoup de dossiers par professionnel
est-ce qu'on est bien outillé est-ce que
est-ce que le système fonctionne en
réalité il faut avoir en tête que le
monde des entreprises en difficulté
c'est un monde de TPE l'immense majorité
des dossiers sont de toutes petites
entreprises et dans le dans le dossier
qu'on vous a remis vous verrez notamment
un document qui s'appelle typologie
d'entreprise
euh pardon c'est la page d'avant
euh juste avant
pardon je vais y arriver il y en a une
sur les procédures de prévention donc on
commentera et voilà pardon j'y suis
c'est celle qui s'appelle nombre
d'emplois concernés par les procédures
collectives par taille d'entreprise vous
voyez que sur depuis le début de l'année
43000 procédures collectives c'est en
bas de la page 26000 concernent les
entreprises à zéro
salariés donc l'impact sur l'emploi par
définition est nul et si vous ajoutez
les entreprises entre à Z0 salariés ou
de 0 à 10 salariés vous êtes déjà à
40000 sur les 43000 000 donc c'est un
monde de TPE c'est bien ça qu'il faut
avoir en tête contrairement à l'image
qu'on s'en fait souvent on pense que
c'est des grandes entreprises qui qui
font défaut vous voyez que cette année
notamment on aura eu au total 10
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés qui
auront connu une procédure collective
c'est un chiffre assez haut par rapport
à ce qu'on connaît d'habitude je reviens
au au chiffres et à la question il y a
une hausse considérable depuis 2 ans du
nombre de défaillances mais le nombre de
défaillan était très anormalement fait
en moyen long terme en France on a selon
la conjoncture entre 50000 et 60000
défaillances par an c'est la première
page du document qu'on vous a remis vous
voyez le nombre de procédures depuis
2015 on était à 60000 en 2015 59000
55000 54000 donc on est entre 50 et 60
sauf pendant le covid où on est tombé à
32000 et 27000 c'est le quoi qu'il en
coûte je vous disais une entreprise en
difficulté c'est quand elle peut pas
payer ses dettes à partir du moment o on
lui dit mais tu n'es pas obligé de payer
ni ton URSAF ni ta TVA ni ton loyer
pendant un certain temps et par ailleurs
tu as un PGE forcément il y a moins de
défaillance donc c'est mécaniques il y a
eu moins de défaillance il y a bien sûr
un effet rattrapage bien sûr qu'il y a
un effet rattrapage mais on voit que les
chiffres de cette année en forte hausse
nous conduisent à fin octobre à 43000
procédures collectives donc on va être à
la fin de l'année probablement autour de
50000 on est plutôt dans le bas de la
moyenne long terme donc il faut bien
avoir en tête qu'il absolument pas de
tsunami il y a pas de vague on revient à
l'étiage normal de l'économie
française une défaillance d'entreprise
c'est normal quand on crée en France des
dizaines de milliers d'entreprises tous
les ans des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises statistiquement il est
inévitable qu'il en a qui marche pas
donc dans une certaine mesure il y a un
niveau de défaillance qui est naturel et
qui est incompressible s'il y avait pas
de défaillance ça voudrait dire qu'il y
a pas de prise de risque et ça voudrait
dire que l'économie va très
mal quelques mots complémentaires sur
les les chiffres pardon j'aurais dû le
préciser tout à l'heure vous voyez qu'on
vous présente des chiffres qui sont très
détaillés par typologie d'entreprise par
région par secteur d'activité par nombre
de salariés le Conseil national des
administrateurs et des mandataires
judiciaires collecte toutes les semaines
les données dans les logiciels métiers
des professionnels vous avez tout un tas
de sources il y a enfin les greffiers
vous donnent des chiffres la Banque de
France vous donne des chiffres il y a
plein de gens qui donnent des chiffres
la question c'est d'où viennent les
chiffres en général ils viennent des
greffes qui ouvrent un dossier en
l'occurrence à chaque fois qu'un dossier
est ouvert il y a toujours so un
administrateur judiciaire soit un
mandataire judiciaire qui nomé soit les
deux et nous avons l'obligation de
rentrer un certain nombre de données
dans nos logiciel métier et donc le
Conseil national qui collecte ces
données c'est sortir toutes les semaines
le nombre le nombre de défauts dans
quelle région dans quel secteur quelle
taille d'entreprise combien de salariés
en direct donc on a les données les plus
précises et les plus régulières qui sont
disponibles sur le marché si je pu
m'exprimer
ainsi il faut avoir en tête que l'autre
grande spité française à part le fait
que les procédures collectives sauvent
beaucoup plus d'emplois que les autres
c'est qu'on fait de la prévention la
prévention c'est quoi quand une
entreprise dépose son bilan ou ouvre une
sauvegarde c'est un événement public ça
révèle ses difficultés au monde et à
partir du moment où vous révélez vos
difficultés vous les aggravez
instantanément puisque vos clients se
disent bah tiens mon fournisseur va
mourir il faut que j'en trouve un autre
vos fournisseurs se disent il va pas me
payer maintenant je vais augmenter mes
tarifs je veux qu'il me paye au cul du
camion vous pouvez plus recruter vos
salariés cherchent du boulot ailleurs
donc la révélation des difficultés les
aggrave automatiquement c'est inévitable
la prévention c'est quoi ça consiste à
dire j'ai des problèmes j'ai besoin
qu'on m'aide mais je ne veux pas que ça
se sache et je peux les traiter sans que
ça se sache et donc je vais voir un
tribunal de commerce un président de
tribunal et je lui demande de nommer à
mes côtés un conciliateur ou un
mandataire àoc qui est un négociateur
qui n'a aucun pouvoir vis-à-vis
d'absolument personne et qui ne peut
rien faire d'autre que de de négocier au
mieux de ses capacités pour rapprocher
les points de vue et bizarrement ça
marche on pourrait se dire ben après
tout à quoi ça sert enfin le chef
d'entreprise connaît mieux son métier
que le conciliateur l'avocat connaît
mieux le droit et le comptable
connaittieux la compta donc à quoi sert
le conciliateur la
négociation dans le monde des
entreprises en difficulté c'est pas une
bonne négociation c'est une négociation
qui est pas dynamique c'est pas du
winwin comme on dit en bon français on
fait pas du bon business ensemble qu'on
est content de faire je suis en défaut
je peux pas payer et le créancier il a
fait crédit et on Nonore pas
l'engagement qu'on a pris envers lui
donc il y a intrinsquement un défaut de
confiance et il y a intrinsèquement des
intérêts qui s'opposent le boulot du
conciliateur c'est de reconstruire la
confiance et plutôt que d'avoir cet
affrontement frontal de construire un
triangle dans lequel vous avez les
partis et au milieu le conciliateur qui
va aider à coconstruire une solution on
a traité on traite tous les ans à peu
près 7000 entreprises dans le cadre des
procédures de prévention le taux de
succès c'est 80 %. qu'est-ce que c'est
un succès le succès c'est on s'est mis
d'accord est-ce qu'on sait vous dire oui
d'accord mais 5 ans après il y a combien
de ces entreprises qui sont toujours
vivantes j'ai pas le chiffre on l'a pas
on est en train d'essayer d'améliorer
les les données mais donc pour avoir des
ordres de grandeur en tête prévention 80
% de succès sauvegarde 2 tiers de succès
redressement judiciaire un/ers de succès
liquidation par définition la société
est liquidée et globalement les 2/ers
des emplois sauvés donc plus on vient
tôt mieux ça marche moins la procédure
est invasive et mieux elle marche et
nous avons en France une boîte à outils
qui est la plus développée du monde et
c'est pas une expression c'est c'est un
fait c'est la plus développée du monde
c'est la plus avancée du monde et du
point de vue de nos critères de succès
qui sont faut sauver les boîtes et faut
sauver les emplois c'est de très loin le
plus efficace des systèmes et ça ne se
fait pas au détriment des créanciers
contrairement à ce qu'on pense en gros
quand on peut comparer les chiffres
quand une entreprise dépose son bilan
partout dans le monde elle va payer à
peu près 20 % de ses dettes
statistiquement en moyenne et c'est le
même chiffre à peu près partout sauf au
RoyaumeUni où ils sont un petit peu
moins bon qu'ailleurs euh je reviens aux
chiffres depuis le début de l'année on a
des procédures collectives qui ont
concerné 187000 salariés arrêtés à fin
octobre donc on va être aux alentour de
200 220000 salariés concernés par des
procédures collectives cette année et
quand je vous disais qu'on sauve les 2/3
des emplois ça veut dire que en gros le
nombre de licenciement pour cause de
faillite de l'employeur va peser à peu
près 75000 destruction d'emploi cette
année en France et on est donc à peu
près dans un étiage normal de l'économie
française avec des entreprises qui qui
naissent qui vivent et qui meurent et
c'est la vie normale des affaires
euh j'en terminerai pour vous dire qu'on
a donc cette analyse sectorielle une
analyse régionale on peut évidemment
rentrer dans le détail si vous le
souhaitez nous on ne voit pas de
secteurs particuliers dans lesquels il y
aurait une poussée particulière on sait
que
évidemment le le monde de la S raitance
automobile vit une transformation
absolument
radicale ça pas grand chose ni pe ni
peut rien sauf à essayer d'attirer des
investissement en même temps que les
entreprises se ferment il faut
absolument ouvrir d'autres on a
l'immobilier qui commence à souffrir
assez fort et c'est le début et on sent
bien que ça va probablement durer
s'aggraver audelà de ces deux secteurs
là spécifiques l'économie est pas très
dynamique mais ça je ne vous apprend
rien on est plutôt toujours un éétiage
bas où est-ce qu'on sera l'année
prochaine on n pas de boule de Crist
mais voilà pas de raison de penser que
les choses ni s'amélioreront
considérablement ni ne se dégraderont de
façon
spectaculaire merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président per à
vous merci merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs les sénateurs de de
m'accueillir vous ne me connaissez pas
je suis président de la conf et Madame
pardon et moi Madame pardon madame et
messieurs je suis président du tribunal
de commerce de la Val et par ailleurs je
suis président la Conférence générale
des juges consulaires de France qui
représente 3700 juges comme vous le
savez en France et qui est répartie de
134 tribunaux de commerce en France et
qui attendent évidemment avec beaucoup
d'intérêt ce n'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui mais je le dis euh la la
réforme qui permettra de mettre en œuvre
le le tribunal des activités dites
économiqu qui sera étendu comme vous le
savez au au monde
agricole je crois que euh
la prévention est en effet un sujet
majeur maître habitbol vient de nous le
dire très bien et je crois que en effet
si ça fonctionne bien c'est parce que
cette procédure est confidentielle elle
est sous la haute protection non pas de
la juridiction mais du
président et qui évidemment offre un
mentat de justice au consiliateur ou
mandataire ad hoc qui aura été
désigné au-delà des deux objectifs
poursuivi par la loi B d'Inter
finalement du 25 janvier 85 qui vient
nous dire en effet premier objectif
c'est la préservation de l'emploi la
périté évidemment de l'entreprise et le
texte ne le dit pas mais vous le savez
bien et accessoirement le paiement des
créanciers il y a dans tout ça un autre
objectif qui n'est pas dit c'est celui
de ce qu'on appelle gentiment ou
publiquement le le principe de de
l'assainissement des proc des des
professions commerciales vous savez que
le le débiteur qui se trouve en état de
sation de paiement a une obbligation de
de faire sa déclaration de sation des
paiements dans les délaiis de 45 jours
et on voit bien que que le fait de
laisser des entreprises qui ne sont
finalement pas viables a un effet sur le
tissu économique c'est c'est un fait et
donc effectivement l'assaainissement des
professions commercial via le les
procures collectives est un point
évidemment majeur je vous le disais
cette procédure est confidentielle et en
même temps le seul moyen de pouvoir
traiter le patient qui est devant nous
c'est d'avoir les meilleurs outils
on n'imagine pas un chirurgien pouvant
faire son opération sans avoir de outils
ad hoc et il y a un outil que le
président de dispose pas et qui me
paraîtrait un outil très utile à la
prévention des difficultés entreprises
c'est celui des difficultés que connait
le débiteur avec l'administration
fiscale en général ce sont des des
éléments qui évidemment donnent une
lumière sur le sujet et l'administration
fiscale ne les communique pas au
Président c'est un des organismes qui
les communique pas et je pense que dès
alors que l'administration fiscale ne
les communique pas pour des raisons de
confidentialité ce qu'on comprend mais
le président lui-même estant tenu à la
confidentialité je je ne vois pas quel
pourrait être les motifs pour lesquels
on ne pourrait pas les donner au
président et je crois que ça serait un
outil utile à la prévention des
entreprises puisque c'est un signe
avantcoureur de cette défaillance et je
crois que de ce point de vue on nous
nous pourrions faire une avancée majeure
de de de ce point de vue je parle
évidemment des des des créances fiscales
mais également des des créances sociales
il y a un deè de sujet que j'ai à
l'esprit je sais pas si le président
bitb le partage mais vous savez que les
organismes de caisse de retraite
notamment peuvent elles-mêmes obtenir un
titre exécutoire pour poursuivre le
débiteur enfin le l'entreprise par le
biais de la voie de la contrainte et
donc évidemment le président dans les
dans les prérogatives qui sont les
siennes il a un ce nombre de d'outils à
sa disposition donc les assignations les
les privilèges qui sont portés ou encore
les les les Procé d'injonction de payer
mais cette procédure en question qui
concerne donc les titres exécutoires
pris par ces organismes là est méconnu
du président et là aussi c'est un un des
signes qui privent le président d'un
outil qui permettrait justement de
pouvoir travailler plus avant en
prévention voilà ce que je peux vous
dire Monsieur le Président à titre
liminire si vous avez des questions je
suis bien évidemment à votre disposition
moi je crois que la compétence du
Président du Tribunal est bien connu en
matière de prévention elle sera
évidemment par hypothèse étendue au
monde agricole et je pense que c'est
vraiment un une belle avancée parce que
encore une fois ça a été dit pendant de
nombreuses années c'est redit on n pas
trouvé de mots mieux que celui-là mais
l'anticipation l'anticipation
l'anticipation et je crois que le le Jef
d'entreprise finalement qui vient devant
le président du tribunal dans le cadre
des préventions des diff difficulté des
entreprises finalement est aussi soulagé
il y a une chose dont on ne parle pas
malheureusement mais qui est réel c'est
celui du soutien psychologique que le
président va donner au chef d'entreprise
qui arrive dans un état moral toujours
très difficile alors que le président
évidemment il a pas d'outil de remède au
sens de la posiologie médicale mais il a
un appui psychologique très important et
c'est vrai que c'est très utile au chef
d'entreprise et l'expérience nous montre
en tout cas de ceux qui ont eu
malheureusement pas la chance de passer
par cette procédure se rendent bien
compte que c'est très
utile merci monsieur le Président euh on
va passer maintenant aux échanges et et
et aux questions de mes collègues
j'avais juste un petit point à à sur
lequel je souhaitais appuyer suite à vos
intervention c'est sur effectivement le
droit à la défaillance et le droit entre
guillemets si je peux me permettre
d'être un peu trivial de se planter euh
et et c'est pas forcément une honte et
mais ça peut également et d'ailleurs si
tous ces moyens sont mis en œuvre pour
accompagner des défaillances et faire en
sorte que ça se passe le mieux possible
sauvetage de l'empfloit et cetera c'est
que ça fait partie des choses qui
arrivent dans la vie d'une entreprise
mais ça doit aussi donner un droit à
rebondir et on doit pas et c'est
quelquefois un peu le cas dans notre
pays par rapport à des pays anglo voir
les États-Unis on doit pas traîner une
défaillance d'entreprise comme on traîne
un boulet toute sa vie et on doit
pouvoir donner la possibilité aux gens
qui se sont alors tout dépend ce qui
fait que l'entreprise s'est planté bien
sûr si c'est pas volontaire mais que
chacun a le droit également de rebondir
et de repartir avec la possibilité à
nouveau d'être chef d'entreprise pierre
quiipers a une question sénateur de la
scmarne Merci
présidentitb Avaz évoqué tout à l'heure
le fait que dans le monde il y avait 20
% des dettes qui étaient payé alors
est-ce que ce sont des dettes
kirographèire c'est dire par des
privilégiés ou est-ce que ça rembourse
véritablement des fournisseurs quelque
part c'est ma première question la
deuxème sur
l'agriculture est-ce que les éléments
déclencheurs c'est
quoi quand un agriculteur est en fa il
se renferme sur lui-même et il faut
trouver les éléments qui permettent
justement de l'aider de l'accompagner en
anticipation mais suffisamment tout par
quel moyen par des leviers sociaux parce
que quand il arrive à ne plus payer
ses sa protection sociale il est déjà
bien trop tard ça veut dire qu'il a pas
réglé non plus ses fournisseurs et qu'il
est en difficulté est-ce qu'on a les
moyens aujourd'hui d'anticiper
l'anticipation quelque part et puis
concernant toujours l'agriculture
puisque j'en suis un c'est sous forme de
société il y a moins de faillite ou
moins de dépôts de bilan en société que
probablement en entreprise individuelle
non
voilà alors sur le sur le passif
globalement j'ai pas donné le chiffre
d'ailleurs c'est 7 milliards par an en
France qu'on paye à peu près au
créanciers tous les ans ce qui veut dire
que bah par définition le passif des
entreprises qui ont déposé le bilan
c'est qure fois ça c fois
ça non on paye pas beaucoup de
chyographire parce que on paye dans
l'ordre des privilèges et dans l'ordre
des privilèges ça veut dire qu'il faut
rembourser d'abord le super privilège
puis les dettes de la procédure puis le
Trésor public puis leur SAF puis les
créanciers
kirograpair puis les créanciers
hypothécaires par exemple tous ceux qui
ont pris des sûretés donc l'État a une
sûreté de droit c'est le privilège du
Trésor les caisses de sécurité sociale
ont une sûreté de droit aussi c'est le
privilège des caisses de sécurit
sécurité sociale qui passe devant le
trésor mais pardon derrière le trésor
mais devant
l'quirographèire derrière il y a les
banques dont c'est le métier de prêter
et qui donc aussi ont pris des sûretés
et le fournisseur il est derrière il a
pas de sûreté bon et donc quand on paye
20 % et ben en général 20 % c'est
absorbé par les créanciers privilégiés
donc on paye très peu de chirographè
d'où le sentiment général qui est de
dire en fait quand une boîte dépose son
bilan elle paye jamais personne pass si
mais elle paye les créanciers
privilégiés et donc très peu les
fournisseurs effectivement sauf réserve
de propriété et cetera tout un tas de de
mécanismes qui permettent de le faire et
et évidemment les salariés sont toujours
payayer de absolument l'intégralité de
ce qui leur est dû il il y a aucun débat
là-dessus évidemment en ce qui concerne
les agriculteurs alors oui il y a moins
de défaillance dans les sociétés que que
que dans les entreprises individuelles
mais notamment parce que c'est un signe
quand on est en société que c'est déjà
un peu plus structuré un peu plus
important un peu mieux outillé et donc
un peu plus solide et donc effectivement
il y a moins de défaillance plus
l'entreprise grandit et plus elle est
solide ça veut pas dire qu'elle est à
l'abri de tout mais mais il y a
statistiquement forcément un peu moins
de défaillance et comment faire pour les
aider plus les agriculteurs c'est
toujours des sujets humainement
extrêmement difficiles c'est c'est
souvent plusieurs génération c'est des
gens qui font qui peuvent pas inventer
un marché quand le marché est difficile
ils ont aucun pouvoir de négociation
avec leurs clients ils peuvent pas
augmenter leur productivité au-delà de
de ce qui est matériellement faisable
ils doivent suivre des règles de
notamment environnemental extrêmement
stricte je dis pas que c'est bien ou pas
bien c'est comme ça ça existe et donc
ils sont dans un environnement
incroyablement
contraint et il y a pas de solution
juridique en tout cas à ça la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
réorganiser le rapport de force entre
leurs clients notamment les coopératives
tout un tas de sujets que vous maîtrisez
beaucoup mieux que
moi monsieur le sénateur vous avez dit à
juste raison anticipation de
l'anticipation finalement c'est ça que
vous dites et vous dites où sont les
signaux que que vous aurez je crois
qu'effectivement il y en a pas en même
temps l'expérience que nous avons de ce
point de vue est proche de zéro donc il
faudra probablement que on profite de de
cette mise en œuvre pour regarder
comment effectivement on peut anticiper
l'anticipation je crois que c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est très bien vu et c'est
vrai que les les signes qu'on peut
trouver ce sont des signes classiques
que vous avez d'ailleurs cité qui sont
les signes de la défaillance du
nonpaiement de de toutes les affaires
dites sociales auxquelles est confronté
l'riculteur mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui les organisations agricoles
sont quand même assez tournées comme des
entreprises on le sait bien aujourd'hui
un agriculteur c'est quelqu'un qui qui a
les mêmes compréhensions que le chef
d'entreprise et je pense que de ce point
de vue cette extension est est une bonne
chose je sais pas si vous le savez mais
la première des causes des de
défaillances des ENT is en France c'est
la première des causes c'est la
défaillance du compte client défaillance
du compte client qui représente 25 % des
causes des défaillances des entreprises
et et donc il faut avoir ça en tête et
il faut aussi avoir en tête quelque
chose de que que vous savez parfaitement
j'en fon des portes ouvertes mais dans
une entreprise le seul compte qui
rapporte c'est le compte client vous ne
trouverez aucun autre compte de
l'entreprise en dehors du compte client
qui rapporte le reste ne sont que des
comptes de dépenses d'accord en l'état
de de de des sujets relativement à la
cyber criminalité qui est un sujet
majeur qui vous avez également tous à
l'esprit on note que les risques
relativement à la
cybercriminalité cyberataque vont
devenir la première des causes des
défaillances des entreprises on a
aujourd'hui des entreprises qui sont
attaquées et qui ne se remettent pas de
ces situations là il faut avoir ça
également à l'esprit
merci merci question de Michel Masset
sénateur du
lotgaron merci Président vous faire part
d'une initiative en lotgaron nous avons
principalement trois pôles d'activité
autour autour bien sûr de de l'axe
autoroutier et donc on a des groupes de
sachant qui se sont réunis bénévoles on
y retrouve à l'intérieur donc un avocat
notaire ancien chef d'entreprise
et donc c'est une première étape pour
accompagner les entreprises qui aiment
bien parler aux entreprises également
lorsquelles sont en difficulté et on a
une structure comme ça de exactement qui
fonctionne relativement bien en terme de
PR conseil justement je juste faire part
et ce sont des sachants
bénévoles juristes la plupart mais
aussif d'entreprise qui viennent
accompagner des entreprises en
difficulté
merci pour ce témoignage chers collègues
moi j'aur j'aurais une question à vous
poser messieur les présidents également
on a entendu tout à l'heure lors de la
précédente table ronde qu'il y avait un
sujet sur l'étalement du remboursement
des
PGE est-ce une source de défaut
prépondérante cette année selon vous au
niveau des défaillances d'entreprise et
le remboursement des PGE a-t-il pris la
priorité sur les autres créances et
enfin une deuxème question avez-vous des
informations sur la situation des délais
de paiement est-ce une raison de la
fragilité des PME en ce
moment faut toujours rendre à César ce
qui vient à César c'est des questions
qui m'ont été soufflées par nos
administrateurs monsieur le Président je
veux bien répondre à votre dernière
question vous parlez en réalité du du
crédit interentreprise et c'est un vrai
sujet bien évidemment puisque en effet
un d'entreprisees sont confronté au non
pement des factures donc évidemment on
voit bien l'effet que ça a ça a un effet
directement sur le besoin en FR rement
de l'entreprise ça oblige
éventuellement les dirigeants ou le
banquier à se mobiliser au lieu et place
du non paiement des de des factures
finalement et et c'est vrai qu'il y a un
rapport de force qui s'opère
actuellement je crois que c'est pas bon
du tout il y a eu des dispositions des
textes qui ont été pris en cette matière
et pour le dire très franchement en
matière du dans le bâtiment notamment
l'État n'est pas le le le meilleur
payeur pour le dire clairement et donc
les entreprises du bâtiment j'ai à
connaître des entreprises qui souffrent
de ce qu' effffectivement ils ne sont
pas payés de leur facture notamment par
l'État les organisations d'éation publi
et c'est effectivement un vrai
sujet al sur le
PGE d'abord le pardon mais le PGE c'est
quoi le quand l'économie s'arrête au
moment du covid on dit aux entreprises
on va vous exonérez de charg on va vous
faire tout un tas d'exonérations on met
en place des subventions on met en place
des tas de choses par lesquelles l'État
prend en charge la perte l'entreprise ne
perd pas d'argent le chômage partiel et
cetera puisque c'est l'État qui paye
donc on sort du covid sans
dette le PGE on dit je te prête de
l'argent pour financer tes pertes donc
on résout le problème en cash mais
maintenant on a une dette donc on a
financé de la perte par de la dette
assez simplement et tout le monde sait
bien que on fait pas ça normalement on
finance pas des pertes par de la dette
on finance des pertes par des fonds
propres quand on quand on peut quand on
peut pas on le finance par de la dette
et ça donne des défaillances ce qu'on
voit régulièrement dans nos
cabinet donc forcément il y a un sujet
avec les PGE maintenant le taux de
défaillance le plus récent qu'on connaît
des PGE c'est à peu près 4 % donc c'est
pas non plus massif ça veut dire que à
ce stade 96 % des PGE se paye on est
qu'en début de phase de remboursement
donc il y aura évidemment plus de
défaillance que 4 % mais on est à 4 % ça
veut dire que c'est pas un tsunami
premier élément deuxième élément il y a
eu de mémoire pardon pour l'impression
du chiffre à peu près 700000 PGE mis en
place pour quelques dizaines de milliers
d'euros c'est des encore une fois c'est
des petits prêts à des petites boîtes
quand il y a la crise financière de 2008
la réponse publique c'était des éléments
macroéconomiques le quantitatifisible
des choses comme ça don on voit pas très
bien comment ça irrigue en vrai la vraie
vie des gens le PGE c'est du vrai argent
prêté pour de vrai en direct sur le
compte bancaire à tout un tas de petites
boîtes moi depuis que je fais ce métier
ça fait 20 ans on me dit bah c'est
compliqué on peut pas investir les
banques prêtent pas on n pas d'argent
pour investir tout le monde a eu de
l'argent pour investir alors pour payer
de la la perte oui mais aussi pour
investir et il y a plein de boîtes qui
ont bénéficié de ce PG alors qu'ell
avaient très peu de concours bancaires
et qui ont profité de ça pour investir
pour acheter une camionnette pour
acheter des choses simples dont les
boîtes avaiit besoin et donc ce PGE au
sens macroéconomique d'abord c'est un
énorme afflux de liquidité pour des
vrais PME françaises et T PEE dont
beaucoup ont fait des choses
intelligentes et donc c'est une très
bonne chose premier élément deuxième
élément il a été
donné quasiment à la demande avec très
peu de vérification en gros comment on
vérifie on dit au banques cou tuassumes
10 % du risque donc tu fais l'analyse
crédit l'état sraite l'analyse crédit
aux banques mais au-delà de ça c'était
ouvert et je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'il fallait faire si on avait commencé
à dire au aux entreprises alors tu vas
avoir un PGE mais attends faut qu'on
vérifie tes comptes ton machin et tout
on tuait la confiance il fallait un
bazooka donc on pense qu'il fallait
faire comme
ça se faisant on savait forcément qu'il
aurait des PGE qui seraient il y a
forcément de la fraude il y a forcément
des PGE malemployés et il y a forcément
des défaillances mais il fallait il y
avait pas de meilleure façon de faire en
tout cas de notre point de vue à
l'époque maintenant est-ce que le PGE
est devenu un problème je rappelle quand
même pardon que ce PGE il a d'abord
apporté du cash aux entreprises et donc
pour certaines entreprises il a apporté
des ressources qui ont été salutaires et
il y a des boîtes qui sortent beaucoup
plus fortes de la crise qu'elle n'y
était entrée certaines il y en a qui
sortent beaucoup plus abîmé évidemment
il y a de tout mais il y a des boîtes
qui sortent plus fortes
donc ce PGE aujourd'hui quand vous dites
prendre un exemple simple un
restaurant à la défense qui qui
fonctionnait à midi parce que les gens
venaient au bureau avant le covid qui a
financé sa paume avec un PGE et on lui
dit bah tu sais quoi maintenant en fait
les gens ils bossent plus le vendredi
ils viennent à moitié le
mercredi et puis et puis tu as toujours
ton PGE à payer et au fait ton loyer
c'est plus 3 % parce que c'est indexé
forcément ça marchera pas donc dans la
masse oui il y a plein de boîtes qui ont
des problèmes de remboursement de PG ge
euh mais encore une fois au sens macro
il fallait le faire et c'était un bon
outil euh maintenant il faut aussi avoir
se poser la question est-ce que des
boîtes meurent à cause du PGE c'est ça
la question parce que si on dit on a des
difficulté de remboursement du PGE et
donc on fait un mandat à dooc et on
réétale le PGE c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave du tout l'entreprise est toujours
vivante elle peut pas payer sur 6 ans
elle payera sur 10 ans pas de sujet la
question c'est est-ce que des boîes sont
liquidé parce qu'elles sont pas capables
de payer leur PGE et on en revient à la
boîte à outil des procédures collectives
en France quand une entreprise dépose
son bilan il y a trois sorties possibles
la liquidation judiciaire donc la
mor le plan de redressement je vais
payer mes dettes j'ai besoin de temps
mais je vais les payer sur 10 ans
maximum c'est le réaménagement du PG pas
de problème et entre les deux je peux
pas j'arriverai pas je suis pas assez
rentable mais la boîte est viable et ben
ça un plan de cession et donc on va
chercher uneneur et al oui le chef
d'entreprise et per entreprise mais ce
qu' l'a créé l'écosystème les salariés
les fournisseurs les clients ça vit
encore entre les mains despreneur donc
c'est un moindre mal donc il y aura pas
à notre sens de disparition
d'entreprise de disparition d'activité
économique parce qu'on peut pas payer
des PG il y a des boîtes qui vont qui
sont en difficulté bien sûr mais toutes
les entreprises viables on peut dire
qu'on les sauve aujourd'hui en France
merci merci Monsieur le le le président
j'avais après Denis Bouan mais une
question de anneesophie Romani sénatrice
de la Marne merci président j'avais
effectivement une question par rapport à
à ces outils de de prévention pour
reprendre les propos de de mon collègue
tout à l'heure par rapport aux
agriculteurs mais de manière plus large
à toutes les entreprises individuelles
et les toutes petites entreprises
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens
d'avoir un contrôle de leur
entreprise très précis parce que parce
que pris dans leur activité on parlait
d'anticipation nous parlions également
de la difficulté de trouver des
indicateurs à ces défaillances je
voulais savoir quels étaient vos moyens
de communication auprès de ces
entreprises comment prévenir faire la
communication sur la prévention pour
être justement bien en amont parce que
aujourd'hui un entrepreneur est submergé
d'information de toutes part et à un
moment comment est-ce que on peut
inclure cette notion de prévention de
défaillance dès la création d'entreprise
ou la reprise de l'entreprise pour que
on est des des entrepreneurs qui soient
bien
avertis voilà très très tôt
oui madame la
sénatrice évidemment que vous faites une
une bonne remarque et une belle remarque
le sujet du monde dans l'entreprise
c'est aussi le sujet de l'expert du
chiffre l'expert du chiffre qui est
auprès de l'entreprise qui lui a une
vision des clignotants et ce qu'on
observe lorsque les les les les
entreprises en difficulté viennent
devant nous on observe que très souvent
elles-mêmes ne savent même pas si leur
activité est viable c'est ça le sujet
vous avez des entreprises aujourd'hui
dans le bâtiment qui passent des marchés
et qui n'ont même pas conscience que le
marché n'est pas viable dit autrement il
aurait mieux valu ne pas le prendre sauf
que qu'est-ce qu'on confond on confond
l'activité avec le savoir-faire des des
des collaborateurs qu'on veut conserver
on veut également on pense qu'on amortit
nos charges fixes d'accord et dans même
temps on pense que il faut quand même
pas trop augmenter les prix au risque de
voir le marché nous échapper au profit
d'un concurrent et donc le le le le vrai
sujet à mon sens qui qui devrait pouvoir
être mis en œuve ou qu' faut faudrait
qu'il soit mis en uvre passe par
l'expert du chiffre l'expert du chiffre
qui doit donner à l'entreprise des
indicateurs pour lui permettre de savoir
quelle est sur une route clissante
qu'elle est sur une route avec un
réservoir avec peu de carburant et et et
d'accepter de considérer queil faut
mettre la voiture au garage si
effectivement quand on passe ce marché
on sait qu'on dégage des pertes et ça
c'est pas acceptable c'est ça le vrai
sujet donc je pense que la solution elle
est probablement chez l'expert du
chiffre qui lui-même en lien permanent
avec l'entreprise et qui est à son
chevet j'allais dire presque en
permanence et au quotidien mais l'expert
du chiffre n'a pas la compréhension à
mon sens du droit des processions
collectives craint même de venir en
prévention devant le président du
tribunal et probablement participe à un
retard pour amener son client devant le
président de la juurridiction voilà ce
que je voudrais vous dire de manière
assez concrète mais je pense que bitb
n'aura pas grand chose de plus à dire
que ce que je viens de dire pardon de ma
bestime mais c'est quand même comme ça
donc effectivement rien à rajouter
Président je n'oserais pas
monsieur Denis bouad sénateur du gare
merci
Président on voit que il y a quand même
un certain nombre d'entreprises toutes
les anné son des défaillant c'est vous
avez les différents processus que vous
avez évoqué on a eu le covid PE très
compliqué quand même pour ce pays on a
eu ce gouvernement qui s'est bien qui a
bien travaillé dans ce domaine pour
sauvegarder le maximum d'emploi et un
maximum d'entreprise les régions les
départements ont cofinancé au travers de
l'aide du département je crois que
c'était une bonne chose à l'époque
j'étais président de département et je
l'ai fait et je le regrette pas il y
avait un certain nombre d'entreprises
qui é quand même en difficulté avant le
covid nous avons aidé ces entreprises
c'est bien pour une fois en France on
avait des procédures simplifiées c'est
pas tous les jours que ça arrive ça
mérite ça mérite être souligné quand
même donc on avait des procédures
simplifiées la question elle est un
petit peu bizarre quand même est-ce que
par le fait que ces entreprises qui
étaient déjà en difficulté que nous
avons quand même aidé que nous avons pas
sorti de la difficulté est-ce que vous
aviez-vous déjà une analyse qui
permettait de dire là on investit à fond
perdu là on sait qu'on va dans un mur
parce que parce que moi je pensais à et
je sais pas si si ce que vous en pensez
vous moi je disais qu'il y avait trois
catégories d'entreprisees dans ces
difficultés là il y avait celle qui
avait pas besoin du PG pas besoin des
Z dans mon département je les
connaissais il y a qu' aller dans les
terrasses des restaurant et des bistr là
où la terrasse est neuve c'est pas
compliqué ça s'est plutôt bien passé
quand même il y avait celles qui avait
besoin qu'on les accompagne parce qu'il
y avait un moment difficile à passer et
si on les accompagnait pas less allaient
mourir ça c'était dramatique et il y
avait celles qu'on a aidé quand même don
on Savit que l'issue serait quand même
fatale est-ce que vous vous l'aviez
ressenti ça ou est-ce que vous avez fait
comme moi vous avez fait un constat à
postérior je pense qu'on le savait enfin
quand on dit aux entreprises on va
toutes vous aider on sait bien qu'on
vaer des entreprises qui ont pas besoin
des entreprises qui ont besoin et des
entreprises qui vont mourir de toute
façon parce que si un restaurant est pas
bon vous pouvez subventionner autant que
vous voulez il est toujours pas bon donc
il va finir par disparaître donc oui
mais et vous l'avais dit je CIS qu'il
faut pas regretter ce qui a été fait il
fallait un message hyper clair on l'fin
on l'a vécu quand quand on ferme tout au
début du confinement enfin c'est la
panique plus personne ne paye personne
on l'a vu des grosses boîtes qui
arrêtent de payer leurs sous-traitant
qui arrêtent de payer leur sous
sous-traitant et et et l'économie
s'arrête ça aurait pu être dramatique
donc il fallait un
bazooka on pouvait pas faire autrement
et donc je crois qu' vous avez raison il
fallait accepter ce niveau de perte en
ligne je vais encore plus loin est-ce
que c'est mal on se dit je vous disais
tout à l'heure je vous dis qu'un succès
c'est quand on trouve un accord mais 5
ans après est-ce que la boîte est
toujours vivante c'est quoi un succès à
quoi ça sert tout ça est-ce que c'est
mal d'avoir aidé une boîte qu'elle est
très mal dont on pensait qu'elle allait
pas s'en sortir mais on l'a aidé quand
même et elle va finir par mourir bon
d'abord il y a des fois où on se plante
et elle finit pas par mourir ça arrive
bon et puis il y a des fois on s'est pas
planté elle finit effectivement par
mourir est-ce que c'est de l'argent
public mal
employé à l'échelle macro quand on voit
ce que ça représente par rapport à ce
qu'on risquait franchement c'est
epsilonesque mais même en regardant le
cas précis qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
entre-temps bah les mecs ont eu du
boulot euh l'entreprise est restée
ouverte les salariés ont continué à
toucher leur salaire on a bah on a perdu
le PGE si on avait pas aidé euh la boîte
aurait fermée elle aurait pas payé sa
TVA elle aurait pas payé du RAF les
salariés auraient touché le chômage
est-ce que ça aurait été moins cher je
su pas sûr
donc vraiment globalement je pense que
la réponse est pour pour public était
était celle qu'il fallait
oui je je je partage votre votre point
de vue d'un point de vue macro quel est
quel est le sujet maintenant c'est vrai
que lorsque vous maintenez des
entreprises qui ne sont pas viables sur
le terrain économique ça crée une
certaine forme de concurrence déloyale à
l'égard de celles qui effectivement sont
un capacité de gagner de l'argent c'est
peut-être juste ça le sujet mais c'est
presque anecdotique je veux dire
est-ce qu'on a fait le tour des échanges
et des questions est-ce que vous avez
tous eu réponse à vos questions voilà
moi je je je tiens question je tiens
sincèrement à vous à vous remercier
Monsieur les présidents pour V
disponibilité et puis je je je tenais
aussi au fur à mesure des échanges à
vous remercier parce que et je pense que
alors vous avez vous avez des
responsabilités peut-être pas un temps
disponible indéfini mais je ne peux que
si je peux me permettre vous encourager
à à faire ce genre d'échange pourquoi
parce que on a toujours l'impression que
votre métier vos
responsabilités on est plutôt dans un
monde un peu froid et moi j'ai pu
dénoter ce matin et et vraiment je vous
en remercie et c'est rassurant mais je
le savais déjà mais ça c'est bien aussi
que d'autres collègues puissent s rendre
compte euh que et j'ose le mot que vous
manifestez également une certaine
bienveillance et vous avez cette
attention auprès des chefs d'entreprise
et et et moi ça me rappelle quand
j'étais quand j'ai fait mes études mon
premier cours d'économie et gestion
d'entreprise j'avais un prof qu'on
appelait qui était un peu le vieux de la
vieille et qui avait commencé son cours
à nous poser une simple question pour
vous c'est quoi une entreprise alors
nous on était des jeunes fous des jeunes
loup on a tout sorti he des machines des
marchés gagner de l'argent et cetera et
et il nous a regardé au bout d'un moment
il nous a dit bouredan une entreprise
est un vendou des femmes et des hommes
homme et si vous avez pas compris ça
vous irez pas loin dans le monde de
l'entreprise mais vraiment merci parce
que vous avez remis l'homme dans le
terme général dans le sens général du
terme au centre des choses par un côté
bienveillant et et et je pense que ça
n'empêche pas la performance ça
n'empêche pas l'exigence la
compétitivité mais c'est bien de
remettre l'humain au centre des choses
merci beaucoup je demande juste à mes
collèg 2 minutes une fois que j'aurai
raccompagné les présidents pour une ou
deux petites communications entre
guillemets internes mercitiation merci
beaucoup à tous merci beaucoup merci